we live welcome to the last bird with
Laura Cognito Antibes artists special
campfire addition we have another guest
here what's going on e yeah it's been
kind of one of those weeks there's been
there's been some thoughts going around
the Twitterverse especially as yesterday
for sure but before we get into anything
in this world we've got a man joining us
today yeah definitely just gonna lay the
voice right here on it for you guys so
I'm gonna send it right back so let's
see if we can get him to turn the color
of his shirt here we go let's do it but
welcome to the last word episode number
97 real way from 100 it's another
glorious Friday we're back from the
campfire for some more looters shooter
discussion I'm extremely excited about a
special guest so we gonna get right into
it I want to introduce the Lord whom I
had the absolute pleasure of meeting in
the flesh new mutual friends Lords
cactus HD and myelin games at Guardian
con 2019
knowledge is law one of the coolest
members our destiny community but his
passion for the titan class and
energetic humor make him a must listen
on any podcast
introducing the creating host of the
men-at-arms twitch channel destiny
unfiltered podcast an announcer for the
destiny down under parkas the lord of
the most hilarious wheels on twitter and
our fellow titan who is still waiting on
his secret lab chair while he sits in
pain or his staples would laugh from
tampa and making his debut at the
campfire of the last word
mommy lord man-at-arms how you doing sir
I will pay you to do our show we cash
American dollars everybody by the way
this episode not safe for the little
ones and sensor in this one so you just
gotta listen I mean we're not Jews we're
not telling you how to parent long
overdue man feels like there's like just
yesterday we having drinks over at the
UFC event right and I had no voice I
don't remember we went to the pit at
Guardian Khan and I just it was six of
us that knew it well five listen to each
other and some like a friend of a friend
and I was talking mad [ __ ] like mad and
then I realized halfway through the game
that the dude I was talking [ __ ] to was
directly across from me at the table and
I add because really I'm just playing it
up for the crowd and I just looked at
one point I'm just like we would bug it
out ever the good old town drinks
a-flowing everybody was doing it up man
but otherwise the nap man what's been
going on in our destiny and just in
general it was an opponent you oh uh I
mean in the podcast is every week
because that's getting different I've
been trying to get a lot of people in
dead
I went back to the roots just try to get
in people content creators that people
don't know nice and give them a platform
to kind of give it a little bit of
exposure which we do we do alright on
audio so it but I mean it's you know
we're all friends with predominant
community members I mean we know them we
are the friends of her friends were
buddies whatever it's like I can get
Rick cactus on the show but I'm not
gonna help Rick right I mean Rick Rick's
established got somebody like a ob
katie-cat over in England a couple of
weeks ago she is a phenomenal
personality I mean funny she's an
amazing players amazing raid helper and
just because of the time difference a
lot of people especially like on my
coasts and and the eastern coast would
probably miss her if you have a normal 9
to 5 life because when you get home from
work she's in bed no maybe she's in bed
I don't know sometimes we got back to
that and then with the I'm on day 5 of
quarantine so this is this this hair is
the new normal is to do that like I am a
living anime character when I wake up in
the morning and be like what's up hey
this is just how I wear my hair daily go
for it nope nobody's gonna call you out
right now and be like do what you got to
do man but doing a lot more on Twitch
which I'm just happy to be all there in
people I'm still shocked people tuned in
to watch me and have fun with me I asked
him every string I'm like why are you
guys here a few more show up every
stream and it's amazing and enjoy it
while it lasts before real life kicks
back in another Chris pop acid to eat
how did you get the announcing gig for
DES to be down that is hilarious I was
rolling oh I'll tell the quick version
of story because I talk a lot log
our slave and I became friends through
the bungee forum and we're friends for
several months before I realized he was
the same dude on the ddu that I watched
every week cuz I'm hot I'm [ __ ] with
names like I can hardly remember the
names of guns and destiny right now it's
just my thing it's like if it's not
fantastic I'm not gonna remember it so
you know vlog was not fantastic so I
didn't remember long but I just I sent
him a we would DM each other every day
and I'd be like dude are you the same
dude that is on destiny down under I
watched it every week he's like yeah you
didn't know that I'm like no like
honestly didn't [ __ ] you know he's like
how many [ __ ] log power slaves do you
think there are in the world my eye dude
I don't know it's butt-head us a pretty
unique it's like I drink when I watch
the show I'd just be like it's too loud
dude with no sleeves that's the way
because I would listen to him in the car
wouldn't actually like paying attention
because because of my ignorance he knew
I was actually a like it wasn't like I
was trying to work him for an angles
like oh this is actually like my friend
yeah and I was three years ago so we
were just kicking it around in twitch
one day I'm like he's like dude I don't
know if this is possible what would you
be interested in doing an intro for the
show so I wrote it out and it was like a
one-minute intro couldn't tell you how
many I can do a lot of words in one
minute and I sentence him he's like okay
I can't make any of this work except the
first part so I said okay let me try
something I saw sent him like I said
just pick one of these that you want
I sent him like 27 28 different five
second openings coming to you live from
whatever huh and he goes okay I couldn't
pick one so I'm just gonna do a
different one every week he just he
drops in a new audio line every week and
I have to make we're starting to recycle
up now I need to make another batch form
that freshened it up this became a thing
you when you tooten in the show starts
you don't know what we're going to hear
me you're gonna hear the metal sounds
finally got us beat oh yeah good good
stuff mm-hmm yeah done that was I think
I know I saw you a guardian con but I
didn't really get to actually meet you
there I know you guys caught up later on
but yeah I saw it was it's really sad
that it's not happening this year
because after last year I've got like so
much more and waited with acquainted
with so many people yes not no more
people who they are it's it's
disappointed it's such a good thing but
especially it being in Florida cuz this
place has not got a [ __ ] together
in any way shape or if there's a lot of
states that don't I mean some do some
don't but yeah it's like we just it's
yeah so with everything going on
obviously out in the world right now so
thank you guys for tuning in hopefully
we're gonna keep you entertained to
start your Friday morning and get your a
breakfast on with us in your ears and
this man with the smooth voice pipes
like throwing it down for you guys to
listen but it is a destiny podcast so we
may as well jump in and just kind of
wanted to see what you guys have been
doing this week if you've been playing
and he said you've been streaming
man-at-arms so what have you been up to
everything everything just playing at
all are you like level six I literally
got online yesterday in the title of the
stream was I have no plan it was just
like let's go I don't know what to work
on neck I think the only thing I have
left to do this week would be like a
100k nightfall oh speaking of which we
got to get up in there yeah nothing else
to do oh yes but I have ten golf balls
and forty prisms and very the max is ten
golf balls apparently so that's kind of
sad oh so tip Wow so there's a tip
there's a back so yeah so that's your
all-in at ten mmm which is really small
actually figured it'd be more yeah so I
was like I'm kind of in the same place
just kind of playing a little bit of
everything yesterday Mayhem's a good
place to farm bits if you're looking for
it so just that's a nice way I wish
mayhem was around all the time so is
this just going there chaos blow off
some steam
and now you can earn some bits while you
do it so why not but I'll be when you
say earn the best cuz you're the all
crucible mode right well it's just that
that one goes faster
yeah that's Mayhem's very fast that's
like five minutes like max it's an
insanely good match so and you'll get
about this when they drop so does your
uh what is your subclass of choice being
that you tighten when you may have when
I may have throwing hammers
that's that no that's that's that's
that's the legit answer like if you're
not throwing hammers and may Hale you're
doing it wrong why you son to crash so
I'm doing it wrong but that's okay I was
like I toyed around with Thunder crash
because of that I knew they made the
tweak to it I saw people flying around
for like an hour before they land it was
like alright I got to see how this feels
and you can definitely fly a lot farther
than you used to but it was like I still
think it like one cuz it mayhem
everybody spread out and it's just chaos
anyway it was like I want to run around
and chunk cameras everywhere so yeah
sometimes I strike out but it's like
when you get like the three or four in a
row I'm like feels good what's here
what's your mayhem class of choice
they're cooking you know you're just
Nova bomb and left and right Nova
because that's like if you come inside
nonsense then it's like I gotta shut you
down stop that or if you grouped up I
gotta shut you down Oh visit still paper
can't stand it in that mode I have
something I got a different hunt they've
never had like a shutdown so golden a
tribe you give me but you need it they
need a shutdown they need it I got I
gotta give him that when I was happy
they got that one let me hit it like a
hammer that actually is sudden war dad
making fire in the air where he's at
he's still hovering through it while he
casts and then comes out the other side
fight I'm like you bastard yes I get
into ruts any other thing I get I do it
I'll give you that the president hmm I'm
alright I'm alright with stuff like that
in the game like I'm going I don't wanna
go on a cake let's get it okay it's like
I'm okay with that but the shards of
gallon or version that used to say that
no no that's that was broken nose broken
I mean and listen Titans were broken in
the first year what I mean I'm very
I scream from the rafters give hunters
back to throw a knife and I'm a Titan
I'm like it's not fair they should have
their one-hit kill throw a knife back
let's figure out sir I'm a very fair
person mm-hmm if I hear one more
[ __ ] say talk about balance in
PvP I am gonna lose my [ __ ] let's go
about the fight let's go
but there's what you got a problem with
what so you want everyone to be okay so
what the holidays you want everything to
be fair I think fair so your issue is
people who want balance with subclasses
people who was balanced with weapons
like we have to hold it the whole is
always bitching on the net about balance
in PvP no that's not how that's not how
[ __ ] war works Titans we are I'm a
striker Titan you know what not since
day one since day one the d2 our whole
thing is we tackle you and you die
so the balance is don't let me get to
zero meters and tackle you that's why a
hunter you guys are all spinning
twirling invisible half the time if
that's the lifestyle you pick to play
but I mean a lot of the whinging is
unnecessary because when you look at the
top players in PvP I'm talking about the
top but how many of them are warlocks
most nah I gotta see that I gotta see
the pets I'm gonna give you the list of
top tier Titans sheep we gotta put up
the numbers man I don't I always feel
like hunter was always the more superior
PvP class but again you guys may have to
update them I don't know but um you guys
if you play me out to these warlock
stuff like Oh
like if you're seen fallout play
anything other than warlock it's common
it's comical no fallout is a warlock and
that's cool be a warlock do you but I
mean you have so many other I mean but
that's it there's it yeah if you play
your class correctly that's the game
balance it's like chess no no no we had
that breed nerf supernova was you okay
with that it was fine
oh hell no that was to go taking it too
far
you do not need to be able to throw that
thing every seven seconds
[Music]
no fair is fair juggernaut for striker
Titans before they nerf that thing that
was broken but less than because you
could put on a 100 you can literally put
on a one-eyed mask and do your super and
run around the map forever okay I'm a
Titan and this needs to be nerfed four
times and it's still decent and it's
still deleted there's a couple things
the probably should be deleted you're
correct
one-eyed mask is the Telesto of armor
[Laughter]
nerfed it again in and broke the game's
son of a [ __ ] don't just delete be like
where's my Telesto it's just it's not in
my collections anymore either and they
just stealth delete the whole thing from
the game let's go
blasts Rick the link once you go lock
all right let's see you she's queen
close game yeah when you go when you go
Titan to hunter and you're like hey I
got two jumps and you go tighten the
Warlock I fall down every ravine ever in
life like
yeah floof gang is not gonna go up it's
definitely oh no I honestly I talk [ __ ]
in crucible minutes a warlock I'll be
like I own the air son you just visited
[Laughter]
they just ac-130 up there now though
there is at this point if they're doing
them well I play the dudes like using
that build yesterday the the infinite
floating er and it is it's annoying I'm
okay that it's annoying I'm like I'm
really okay I'm like well if you choose
to stay I'm eventually I'm gonna notice
that you're just staying up there and
the game's gonna change so I'm gonna
give you these free kills but I like
this dude is legit did not touch the
ground every time he'd come around a
corner coming around yeah it's not a
fast glide either he's just any went
from aggravating to finest like he's
just gonna sit there and hover okay
great up yeah I will say that would make
him I just cuz I hadn't played I had
revoke her on my character that I
switched over and jumped into and I
actually pulled a couple fun Snipes with
my revoke her and I was like the fillos
felt really good just randomly in pvp
just it went everybody's like stooping
around and just be like shut down I was
like ooh that feels good
and I'm not a good sniper but when those
hit that felt one one in one fell the
snipers are really strong yeah so
speaking of balance and PvP and things
of that nature
else I wanted to open I got what else I
mean this I was gonna say what does
all-star to talk about but this is the
topic this week so
I haven't listened to DCP they had
theirs last night I'm sure they talked
about it I know Rachel sir on tables
been talking about it I know everybody's
been talking about it and Twitter is
exploding so let's go go ahead let's get
the guest man let's get him in I was
like I wanna move our own guest what do
we feel right now about trial what's
going on I just kind of sit back and
laugh at everyone collectively mm-hmm
because well yeah I think I said the
other night is like you know when trials
at 9:00 came out it was trials of the
miter and then everyone started to
explore but everyone had a might they
gave you a miter I was like so the first
trials was trials of the hard light
mm-hmm and then anomaly came by and I
was like well this is not gonna be fun
and you know what
they turned anomaly into a disco dance
party and I'm cool with that it was just
I was just and then witness oh oh no we
have this this is ridiculous we have to
nerf this gun of
the double damage on ricochet shot I
don't know why that was ever added to
that gun why I'm like this thing is
really out of place we can't fix the
bounce so we got to make sure that the
shots that land actually can't
apparently was the idea they fix the
bounce thing I have no idea what it
means I'm off the ricochet no there was
never in the gun the double dad was
ricochet has been here for a while it
was last year said it must have been
added disability that's like a frickin
laser beams they can reverse that they
can take the double - don't ricochet off
it was unnecessary to begin with but at
least they were trying to get people to
play with it cuz nobody was using I
never thought I would live in a world
people be like hard light is broken yeah
[ __ ] is wrong with you it's a meme gun I
know this I wrote the mean the hell is
wrong with you people but I get it now
we get into widows court and revoke her
is the bad boy of the week
yep and I said so I laugh because I
remember one revoke her was released and
everyone was like so this is just a
Pinnacle gun that rewards bad players
for missing yep they should have a
reward for people who are good at aiming
and here we sit now on widows court
which if you don't use a sniper rifle on
widows you ain't playing the map
correctly yeah I'm not even a gun go go
ahead some people are in but you better
hang on rubble or something yeah yeah
it's not a great trials map because it's
a it's a huge map in this 3b3 so you're
gonna get slower games but now the same
people who are like this gun isn't so
good like oh this gun is broken because
it rewards bad players yeah
it always has but first question is how
many times are you gonna let somebody
shoot at you with the same sniper rifle
really it's like he shot infinite ammo
there's that listen either you or I are
dead in a gunfight after the first 30
seconds it's it's I'm not gonna hide and
let somebody shoot at me nine times
disciple bang come on pop your head
again
just like yeah mm-hmm but it's not but
it's not even you know me being a
moderately a ground polish sniper it's
not even a sniper I would really use
right and except for except for that
perk which is nice to have that but I'd
much rather use my twilight oh third one
of several other aggressive frame
snipers I have in my I don't have a
great one
okay I don't have a great I have one
with I have one with snap shot and if it
doesn't have snapshot I'm not bringing
in PvP but I was like yeah Getti I was
in I have a persuader that it's like I
don't know why it's just the snapshot
animation on my persuader cuz it's like
snapshot sites and I think it's a fast
one or whatever it just is like it's
just so fast for me to zoom in on it
I've had a lot of fun with that one I
haven't pulled it out and a little bit
of trials I'm played just because we're
vocre seem to be the thing to do on that
map but I actually really like that
sniper and I know it's like not met at
all but my father that I guess my
question about homes they still like I
get it with the weapon boy I understand
you get poison but the whole thing right
now everybody's coming down with the you
know the cheating the the issues going
on there and that's the reward so like
where you at with the rewards of the
cheating part well I mean yeah that's
cheating I mean I'm not a smart man I
predicted this many moons ago
this was gonna be a problem on PC or a
trial
it was common sense I mean look I got a
clip on my channel right now somebody
was cheating in mayhem it's live right
and I'll send it to you later I could
under crashed a pole dancer in his super
three times and bounced off of him and
he took zero damage okay I'm like please
clip this please this is live this is
happening everything else around me is
dying let's do just a chiller chiller
it's not I mean it's not gonna be on PC
PC and hacking unfortunately it's it's a
marathon it's not a sprint
yeah to sort all this out I mean Bundy's
being very very proactive they're doing
the best they can't they can't tell us
what they're doing France right software
cuz that's like that's how the mousetrap
works there you go right but it's gonna
it's going to take a lot time here
they'd pull probably you'll probably
never get a hundred percent of it right
I don't know that I don't think they're
doing IP bans I think you're just doing
account bans mm-hmm
moving it to where you had to be a
certain light level to play trials was
nice because it's a little bit of
gatekeeping to get into the game mode I
mean you should be at least I think you
should be a thousand respectfully I mean
cuz I mean legitimately you're 110 is
the cap of pinnacle gear you know
outside of the ornament I think you
should have to be a thousand if you have
a no-life or that's gonna make an
account you don't have a no lifers gonna
make an account but I mean at least it's
it's like a funnel it reduces the amount
of people getting to the bottom right
well that was what we all got to was the
quest was literally bead 960 and I was
like hey make it a seven step crazy
quest and then you can do trials that
way that's a harder thing for people to
repeat as well right and that was yeah I
mean the saint and be like but here we
go bud done make it make it like this is
in a sage quest because I did that the
other day in one sitting and I was
physically tired after four hours like I
gotta go take a nap
I'm done but uh what was the second part
the second part was obviously a lot of
people right now we've got got two
issues with the rewards of flawless and
then people oh yeah you know some of the
higher-end guys farming the three win
bracket I know them they're making the
most of what's out there so it's like I
can't blame the players as much they're
just using the system to the best of
their no indeed one because obviously we
didn't have a token system I mean I
really you you had a chance to get
random loot on pretty much any game like
if you played eight trials game in law
she still had a small percentage chance
to get Luke but you got rewards on three
five and seven and that was it I don't
know why anyway I like the whole
saint-14 concept I don't know why tokens
were introduced into that game mode in
kind of blindsided me
honestly when because I knew st. for but
I figured st. 14 was gonna give you like
your bounties and you do bounties and
I'm you can you have a I mean can we
give him the same rng as banshee with
the the guns I mean you know you throw
in a bunch of world items and then you
could maybe get some trials gear I would
like a d1 I mean this that's what I
don't understand but
they said they're gonna look at they're
gonna tune and I'm glad they addressed
it this week in the 12 yesterday but is
it what I would have done - no but you
knew coming out the gate there was gonna
be issues like this
people used to used to farm three win
cards for a low back in d1 - yeah I
don't know if everybody remembers this
but you would you would actually farm
your elope if you want to have a higher
ela which I now I don't know why you
would want a higher anything yeah I'm
very happy hovering around with my 1kd
because I play like a stupid idiot
having fun when skill bachelor skill
based matchmaking comes in an iron
manner because I'm like yeah I'm
actually really better than this I'm
using three shotguns I got three bows
let's go go yeah let me ask you um I
mean I mean what in what would you like
to see I mean as far as like the reward
system the rewards I first off top
flawless has to be way better reward
like you you have to make that it's not
even equivalent today today nightfall or
hill right so we got to get the golf
balls up you gotta get the shards up you
got to get that going on that's number
one but number the main thing is a debt
weapons like you you have to give that
intrinsic perk we talked about it last
time whatever that what's the cost
celerity or whatever it is II you got to
make that intrinsic this [ __ ] that's not
that much of an advantage if that's an
extra little slot on a gun kind of like
the UM sundial weapons had an extra slot
once you unlock they could do that that
should be easy
you know hopefully they'll put that in
game but yeah you gotta reward that so
this way you can't get the three of them
three when farming but I'm with you men
arms I don't like I don't know why they
went away from the bounty system because
the bounty system in Prior trials was
really good you had incentive just for
playing and then you could get that
branding reward whether it be armor or
it just kept you coming back you know
but that's the main thing not a cheating
look is it is it is
oh it is it is rough it was being
screamed and a car mom you know sinister
was playing and you just get to the
point where you like they know you get
killed you bet
ain't no way this dude kill be legit
like get to that place so it's just like
for me I gotta be real eat until further
notice I might be trials on console
exclusively until I see some improve its
its a lot of people are doing are on the
same page as you
yesterday he was like I'm playing today
doing my PvE stuff on console looking at
my eyes ready for tomorrow and it's like
yeah you got gotta bring the frames down
a little bit to fit though we gotta get
come down to the old video I got my
tunnel vision ready I'm ready
here we go hey I got 4k HD on Xbox at
least is your live/work a tunnel still
good just don't mess with the field of
view you'll be fine I wanna be I wanna
be blind at all times
we gave a they got they got to do
something about it now they you know
obviously we'll talk about what they
addressed that obviously they can't say
specifically what they're doing the gift
that the cheaters are heads-up but sure
I asked across them guys like it's so
easy he was showing how easy it is not
only to get one of them aim box whatever
things is and then someone put a stat up
II I don't know if you saw it with the
amount I had the population of those who
went flawless and the total properly did
you see that list all that number of
quality don't number of flawless runs
first number of bots downloaded was like
equal and you can and you know and you
know this like certain people were going
flawless multiple times so more people
have downloaded that thing then went
flawless which for one means people
don't have to use cheat and to I'm
scared they didn't even get there
but what's that pigeon and then but yeah
it's like it's it the big question I
guess for me on this is it starts to
mess with the integrity of the game cuz
leg yeah if I walk around a corner on
widows court and I'm like cool you shot
me awesome like you're a better sniper
than me
or pretty much hardscope than my dumbass
walked into it mm-hmm on the other side
I'm like now I'm like did you earn that
and if I start questioning that on like
half the shots that happen to me like I
know people are good snipers I've
watched them like damn that's amazing to
watch
but now if I question like just this
random dude that I don't know I'm like
did you actually do that or are you just
sheep and if I wonder that all the time
then it starts questioning what the hell
I'm doing in the first place what's up
mr. Buchan well uh Watts had written
something earlier in the week where she
went and pulled somebody from last
trials and I'm watch as a beast you know
what I mean watches absolutely at least
i watch her every week you know if I'm
available fallout but she's an animal
she was getting aim bought it and she
went pulled these those guys record I
was like okay so you mean to tell me
that you have a hundred percent headshot
accuracy over the last 14 games with 80
headshots [ __ ] exactly much more
political than me but who is that we're
starting to see examples of people with
either you know the steam account bands
or reported you don't know that they've
been some type of foul play and then
they're still allowed to get back in it
so to me they got to issues it's it's
not only fixing and getting better
anti-cheat really what they knew they
were here but the second thing is you
got to work with steam on the back end
right and somehow fix that like no one
with any type of flags on their account
should be able to come back in trials
right back in the mix your doesn't doing
what they've been doing like that's my
issue right now did they've got to be
hard on that well here's an exam a lot
of Call of Duty if I'm not mistaken and
was very very toxic in their youth and
her ps4 as follows carcass flawless
Carla duty as concerned is a brick like
she's out forever
oh oh yeah she's out he's like that no
longer exists and I'm okay with that
like if you mess around - and then as
you're saying it's like hey they can
jump right back in after a vac ban or
whatever they call it on Steam I'm like
maybe like hey you could Gump jump back
in and go but you can't jump into like
crucible like be banned on crucible
right for a long time if you want to go
do PvE stuff yeah whoo a mutt wahoo
but like PvP stuff and that's where
you're gonna screw with people and it's
gotta
I don't know that's to change the check
coming in right all right now all right
I'll sanity said there are they working
on tiles you think they would have built
a anti cheat at some point a better one
yeah I mean I agree with that now almost
far as Lazarus besides IP been and what
could what you do to prevent mitigate
this cheating that that's that that's
the question you know saying and
obviously it's a tough situation cuz
they can't be too transparent with us to
give the the guys you know cheaters the
upper hand now hey it's orchid I ain't
which you now you say they shouldn't
have brought trials back we ain't go we
ain't gonna get crazy pretty good it's
it's a little messy right now but let's
not get crazy
she went flawless I don't want to hear
him right but that's kind of the issue
that we like we before trials ever
launched your mind worse than the
podcasts going hey what does it need
Lords was number one and that was your
number one so it's like cheating the
thing and even I played through it was
like you're gonna see him and especially
like people at the skill level of you
know miss 5,000 watts and stuff like
that she's gonna be at the higher end if
they're facing people who have 80
headshots in a row perfectly then those
two sadly are gonna start seeing each
other more so the higher skill they're
gonna see it more which sucks for them
right but on the other side the whole
everybody across the board is the
rewards it was like you go flawless
you're saying you're not getting a golf
ball or a shard you're like that's fine
I was like but honestly is like when
you're saying at depth if you get armor
should it be fully masterwork and should
be coming in the mid sixties that's
probably if you see an armor from that
masterwork for one it should please
don't let it be like the pit of heresy
master work oh that's so sad yeah that
thing drops out you're like oh I got a
master worked at 62 stat so if I do that
why did I get a 50 what the hell and
they're all like that down there it's
terrible so like high armor stat rolls
from flawless or adept weapons at least
with celerity doesn't seem like it's
that hard and that's at least at a
minimum what should have been in there I
agree I absolutely absolutely they've
got to do it they've got to do it you
know like I said hopefully I'm very
curious to see the thing is they're in a
tough spot cuz like I said you got you
got this going on they gotta work with
steam it's obvious PC only but then
obviously because of you know the virus
how staffed are they you know I mean how
quickly can they be agile today so
they're really the touch but that's why
I said yeah I'm kind of leaning like I'm
gonna be on PC but the weekend I mean on
the console for the weekend it was it
until I just can't it's just too rampant
and here's the other guy I don't know if
we talked about last week um if you went
flawless already no I shouldn't see you
in 1 2 3 I shouldn't see you I should
see your icon that has low Osiris thing
on it with the lights I shouldn't see
anything if you already went flawless
then you should be in a separate queue
separate so you are pressing a fuse brah
get my idea what the playground they
just went to the lighthouse body at the
playground bullying the kids no I agree
I just don't know logistically if it's
possible I was probably on his burger
green if you think about the characters
now they have a tag on the characters
say hey you and you into the lighthouse
your armor glows if your armor glows
you're not gonna play me on my first
card over the entire weekend that seems
like I agree on that one because
somebody's probably good point about a
deaf but remember uh age a triumphant d1
the adept weapons and they were all the
static roles no and they were all good
static roles there were no weapon what
would be wrong with bringing to trials
for Game seven you get an adept weapon
which is a god role and it's a fixed
role and that's like like a came out in
a doctrine of passing with you like say
multi kill clip and feeding frenzy oh my
god everybody would be killing
themselves till the seven wins to have a
chant and that's the only way you can
get that gun that's not going to happen
from the world and that would have
everybody grinding up to Game seven
you're rated roles like that yeah
absolutely well heard another idea was
work at the way the sundial worked you
get to the end and you use your
selection you get your flawless like
they're all unlocked but you just pick
one and this is like you get your and if
it's not curated specifically just to
give more options but you go up there be
like hey
I'm picking the shotgun for my flawless
run on this character and then you'd
have people go into the lighthouse and
if you let him do that constantly with
random roles they would be just going to
the lighthouse over and over and over
and getting out of the bottom into the
car incentive for them to stay in it
longer mm-hm and fight between that five
to seven stay in that mix again stop
bullying kids on the playground because
I mean I can't get mad at them it's the
most efficient thing right yeah you get
two three and you just keep calling
three you get the tokens you go see you
know st. and boom boom but I want you
man arms I miss the old bounty system
and I'm saying I still I don't I don't
know how I feel necessarily with the
token stuff the way it was before was
fine to me because it just required
participation for the people because
listen here's a problem the guys at the
lower end they're feeling crushed right
now they're feeling like I don't got a
shot to get one win right cuz they're
getting pubstomp
you gotta give those guys hope you gotta
give them guys mean willing to the
reason to stay in it in the old bounty
system it's like hey play a couple of
matches get a couple of kills and then
necessarily mean win sometimes it was
just getting kills and just being active
in the event and it'll get them to
staying longer
but you got to do so as much as I love
trials as did you know the competitive
PvP end game you got and let the casuals
cuz somebody had a reddit post I don't
know if you see it it was a good post it
was like it was a casual guy he's like
you want it sweaty you wanted this okay
you're won cuz we're leaving weird it
was a great post and imma got it is bro
hardcore for the PvP but I what I read
it I was like you know what he's right
cuz if he's right
if that base goes is just the sweat ease
anything that doesn't increase the
population of PvP in this or any other
game is bad for the game cuz you you
need as many people playing as possible
for just the matchmaking to work cuz I
mean a perfect example I have a friend
that in he's over in Australia sassing
Sassy's one of those one percenters he's
in [ __ ] Australia so he match makes
out of Australia skill based matchmaking
doesn't work for SAS because he ends up
playing the same
12 dudes every match on skill based
matchmaking sass will hang out with us
when we're running sixes for iron banner
in our discord chat and talk to us but
sassy can't play with us cuz as soon as
sass jumps in our game goes to [ __ ] but
so I get it so with the connection bass
in the car bass for guys like sass and
aura and you know those guys that are
true players yeah it's great for them
and as you get the matchmaking you can
you can get the easier games but when
the population goes down and don't
matter you're just still playing with
the same few hundred people over and cuz
pcs are way smaller than the console
it's like as far as like when you get to
this activity mm-hmm another thing for
the population base for comp which is a
weird place now that's a whole different
animal they put in these solo comp crew
you the free stuff freelance or whatever
you wanna call it
mm-hmm a freelance queue for trials do
you guys think this would be but what do
you guys think how about that one I'm
feeling you're yeah you go you go I want
to know why you say no to me it's it
just seems like would be lfg for raids
mm-hmm I mean in all honesty I mean
offense though it is defense I was like
well technically doing it in uh in call
it's like not doing it and like I mean
people want to go in there for be right
there orchid I love the freelance queue
and that's one of those for the people
who like I mean you're gonna have some
crap games you absolutely are you're
gonna go in there you're gonna rap games
they're not gonna go that well but it's
luck of the draw maybe you come in next
time you get paired up with God sniper
and you're just like somebody who didn't
have any to play with be like hey I'm
gonna get a couple matches in I don't
have a team right now I'm gonna go at
least queue in as a failure this man for
it but I don't think I think it's a
band-aid on a bullet hole oh and I agree
with that I was gonna say like for it
being a solo queue it's like yeah the
population would maybe some solo cues
would go in there and maybe they might
get a feel for it but in turn like their
awards the cheating all the others
stuff in trials itself that's still an
issue but no it's just I wondered if
because I haven't heard Paul has nice I
think
I think soloqueue if you did so acute
trials what it would be Jose you be
everybody would jump in and try to get
their three wins mmm hooker because
basically to get three wins you have
what six tries if you're allowed three
losses for you have to restart a card
yeah right so you so basically you run
and you do your try to get your three
wins at six games and then as soon as
you just like the guys who are farming
trials now you get your three wins you
get your loot you pop out you start your
card over and so there's a solid
argument for it but wait what if the
they fix that part with the the three
wins that we we're complaining about and
they they do what we want would you
still have an issue with the the solo
queue well now you're trying to push to
seven games with randoms every match and
I can fully understand the frustration
of lucky you're on game six you have got
your to losses you're going into Game
seven and you get you know captain
McGillicuddy 0.13 I can see that being
equally as frustrated yes so like I was
saying it's gonna take you know there
like a chat chance for it because they
may have a lot of suggestions and none
of them are wrong yeah so if you take
all the suggestions and you slowly
implement them which is what I think
Bungie is doing right at the end of the
marathon you might have a good system
right yeah it's a good point okay I'm
just saying it's it's not gonna be
perfect but it's every changes don't
happen by flipping a switch
yeah you want to make one change its
you're talking about three to six weeks
between landing testing and release and
then figuring out if it's bugged and he
figured out that broke something else do
you gotta make other changes not quick
here's my issue though
they don't have three to six weeks with
the cheating part that's just me now as
far as the wind stuff they can get away
yeah yeah cuz they could keep changing
up the loop pool on what's the three
right and they can make it bigger you
put boots at the three US a week and
then you can cause items always down
there at the bottom
yeah they might to put the clasp out
they just could just merely shadaloo and
they get past that but if they don't get
this cheap thing together
this is really detrimental you know it's
really detrimental
now as far as the fiction when he may
even a good point about splitting not
splitting the playerbase um why separate
and flawless from nock I do agree them
on that on that level because you've got
to keep it all together you can't have
it that that split it itself even though
I do like the idea of it but it's not
practical like you were saying man else
cuz at the end of the day you're playing
with you random right then you're not
keeping those through yet and you got to
do it again would be another Randle's
another program that is almost you look
I'm sure like soloqueue when you people
solo up the legend that comp yeah but
the problem is I was like that's gonna
get to a point where it's at least a
little sweaty at the top and you can
have some random luck in there if you
keep if you put your head down you keep
playing though you can get too low it's
like a different as opposed to yeah you
lose that three and you're out which
does suck for sure but that's reward for
your time investment even if you are a
below average player well you do it this
is and it's a it's not a bad system 100%
I have not put my head down long enough
to get to legend which I finally need to
do so I am on broken but if you keep
playing and playing the plan you will
eventually get to legend right yeah it's
just about just playing get there with
an elimination style game mode that is
much harder not saying it really is and
then you kind of factor in all the
randomness of the people who you are
with versus where the opponents are with
the card it's a lot of variables and
more probably just their base
it needs to be one all because again if
the numbers are going down you're gonna
get a maximum amount of people in there
and as you can so like how would you how
would you set up the bounties because
and the one I heard and I'll let you go
first but how would you set up the
bounties to me
them kind of enticing to multiple levels
like the only one for example that I
heard was instead of making it even like
winds just make it like you know you'd
get a win for trials like for one of
them you go to win 20 or 30 or 40 or 50
rounds right sounds like you win yeah it
was like I think it was like that before
was like round it was like the amount of
matches or the amount of grenade kills
or the amount of what you call a kill
nothing that required like three wins
and five wins stuff cuz again that's
another barrier right you're telling a
person who is not skilled they've got to
get a certain amount of wins just to
even cash out that's a problem right now
you're demoralizing these guys with the
tokens that's not at least with the
bounty system it's literally in let's
call it what it is participation right
it's it's hey get in there do some
things and then at least you got a
chance cuz there's some people I get I
got shot my point cross he said it like
I was one of those guys that I didn't
have any meta weapons when I first saw
trials but I kept playing week after
week I put and then one week doctor the
passenger out for me in that bounty and
then pull I'm in the mix now and I'm
saying I'm in the competitive spirit and
sometimes that's all it takes you know I
mean so you gotta give those guys hope
to keep playing if they could at least
get this kind of stuff so that I don't
necessarily like the you gotta win three
in order to cash out I'm gonna be honest
that that's the part I'm kind of
struggling don't you think
[Laughter]
it's I mean there's there's there's
several ways you could do it you can
even the crazy idea how does make the
adept weapons part of the triumph and so
we're like for example to get like 15
more mine bits I gotta go shoot 50
people in the head with a sniper rifle
so what would be wrong with okay to get
this adept is old and this is the build
and it's fantastic you have to get three
hundred trials wins
I mean yeah but if you want it the
higher the card you're like the higher
you are in a card the more progress you
make on something give that
incentivization I'm still grinding out
the Lumina quest it's been months the
catalysts are just a quest just to get
the gun cuz I'm just gotta roll around
with this thing [ __ ] I mean but this has
always been a thing if the reward is
great enough then people will do the
work spend the time and place the reward
has to be great enough the armor system
is very broken right now it's I've got
one really good shattered throne armor
piece like you'd mentioned earlier he
and everything else is okay but I didn't
have to spend eight gazillion resources
to master work that that was a free
master work so I'll just slap that on
for the time being and then I have my
collection like I did a vault party the
other day I couldn't I deleted like 200
something items on my it's like I got
all this really great armor him up when
you do a non-vote party - Oh what - all
weapons at this one my armor is almost
gone over there it's all weapon rolls oh
no it was almost all weapons like the
armor was just I like okay I'm getting
rid of all this cuz it's low stat but it
was like okay chat yea or nay and then
it was just like that fights would break
out that's fine but with the armor I
have armor pieces that are you know 65
natural 62 natural they're just in my
vault because I don't want to I don't
have the resources or time or the energy
or the glimmer to that's that works I'm
out of that what is it Seraph whatever
because I was down to like 10,000
glimmer the other day and I was I just
startled and I'm like I spider here oh
how last buy - please I want to go rob
spiders I was like spiders his loan
shark right now and he owes him that
should be a game
where you once once a month you can go
do a mission to rob spider and the only
reward is a buttload of resources there
you go when you get your 50 you like rob
him it's like you get a chance at 500 me
like I'm Quinn but he's on like God Tyr
1060 Grand Master boss mode
I think he's doing it but my dig is I
would say this yo staying calm calm is
actually good resilient it's really good
because you get cuz while you're doing
that you also get into valor right Valor
reset reset quick you get your seven
masterwork corn getting all that stuff
flowing getting the money and you're
getting your bits if you got the UM the
the Seraph thing you want like yeah
they're up in the monk upgrade and stuff
like that cop has been actually Pleasant
as far as staying in there and just
grinding and getting stuff I've been
doing pretty well in there but um yeah
and then now's the weekend you better
get Nana do it
it's the only thing I've left like for
the whole week I have nothing I've
closed out if I can see it's like it's
like a thousand on my own I know you can
do it that thing sucks on your own
though by the way cuz this is the one
where it has three champions all three
Wow so you got to find some way to
manage them all or your punch and
unstoppable guys and praying you don't
get punched back a thousand you go into
orbit if you die mmm no but you will
restart a section like checkpoint you
were start a section also if you're by
yourself it's dicey no once at first
what good I'll say this the first things
I've ever paid attention to the seasonal
mods I have I got one on something I
don't know what it is I got to go back
and look at it but apparently if I punch
anything with a charged melee it creates
an orb yeah and I'm like this is it with
the arc subclass it's probably the art
if you do any arc damage not even kill
like an arc ability damage it drops the
charts so it's like very one of the most
reliable ways to get those things better
I love it yeah that's huge
in PvE any activity I'm dropping in
Leviathan the other day I was like you
get the one also experienced the radius
of the global reach yeah global reach
and it is another one that is good
against UNSTOPABLES and overload
champions but that goes up let's say
artifact mod mm-hmm level 4 so that one
yeah of one it's the void one if you
equip that one you can shoot it like
once and it does the void pulse where it
kind of basically staggers everybody
kind of watch them around like they're
like flashbang Oh a do it they do it a
blow really yeah you can get them and
you can actually end because it takes a
lot of shots sometimes to break the war
mine yellow so you shoot it and be like
and everybody's just like staggering and
you're like working on one guy shoot it
a couple more times it's done some again
they're just getting stacking around you
can like Karns done and I don't you get
you gotta use it yeah and then if you
pair the global reach with the large
earning solar explosion paired with that
one paired with drop in another cell
with arc Lake if you have this is like
that is the most like build centric
thing I've seen in this game ever if you
want to build around warming cells you
can put a mod on every piece of armor
every sick of yeah and then when we get
that machine gun coming then you can
have it in all three weapon slots
dropping that thing yeah that's gonna
leave like legit now I wanted to ask you
like areas that's going back to trials
it was like I know we talked about
bounties and stuff do you one he's
asking and it's like if they took out
tokens and just did the bounties as
stuff to work towards would you be okay
with that do you like the tokens at all
do you want to gone I wanted to kind of
clarify it date they don't disgust me
but I don't feel there was nothing wrong
with the old way of doing it so if they
made that decision to get rid of them
yeah be happy because at the end of the
day the bounties are just rewarding the
play just just just play do what you got
to do don't put this you know this this
ball garden on it and then you know the
farming stuff I think that I would
alleviate some of it at least
and then just incentivize and you know
rewards 5 to 7 on like we talked about
early and stuff like that but back to
your point with that with the sell stuff
is on yeah man um I actually love this
seasonal mods like these these little
mods I'm having a ball man it's like I
did excited I hit you see the ball
trapped in the hole play ball exactly
welcome I love it man especially doing
the arm the video the legendary what is
called los factores is known you can
really create cool synergy with that
stuff I got it me this is the first
season with seasonal mods or Lin it is
fun yeah it's really fun this mechanic
they got one they didn't see the Dornier
charger like yeah not that it wasn't
powerful but this is more practical
effective use in the actual last week so
she's literally having a boy yes having
a boy yes that's that that's type of
time I'm on right now it's fun really
fun I'm enjoying it
yeah it's like I was they have slowly
and I'm curious we're gonna get a couple
more from IO next week because we get
two mobs in each bunker I'll be curious
if disappointed it's not open this week
oh man I could have you not really
disappointed open this week well I mean
okay I'm gonna have a bunch of tokens
right when it opens up by the time
Tuesday rolls around so I'm gonna be
able to close out probably half of it if
not 75% of it and it's just like you
know it's just more fun to be able to go
and grind all that stuff I'm done for
the week and it's like well [ __ ] I'm
sittin at 4700 right now I'm gonna be
able to walk in and be like done and
like well then this is my joke of every
podcast we keep doing I'd be like my
first hour done now what do I do for two
weeks how do you have 47 what do you do
you play her scible I've been working on
my balls you can do lot sectors like and
I'm always picking up those dumb
bounties I'm always picking up those
warm okay so you going back yeah yeah
yeah I'll jump I'll jump back that's why
I have no money there goes there three
thousand dollars you gotta have vision
you gotta have a Rainmaker working all
the time
all the time I can arrange a car yeah
yeah but I immediately as soon as I'm
done with my balance and go back to to
the bunker you know Spyder here let me
ask both the artist are both of you are
using that arm encrypted warm I'm bit
Bing that clears the bunker out for the
week nope do y'all use them no never do
okay no just just go in and run it once
a day it's fun I mean it's like it's
kind of it's fun I do like it and all of
just charging through everything and
like I'm turning on Robo there's a
Shrieker above me I don't care I got a
turn big boy on come on I literally go a
like a sweeping run like underneath the
Shrieker trying to dodge go around the
brick pickup war bind buddy go grab my
Valkyrie turn around shuck the spear at
the step I like I'm trying to have a
game of it and see if I could not die it
was recur the old but he's painful
I have to behave it's fun to try the
beat to clear the bunker improperly like
there's way better ways to do this I'm
not using any of those ways because
there's no risk em it's like the only
thing that's gonna happen is you're
gonna die and then you come right back
as I come right back you can actually
have fun with it yep I'm doing this
melee only well that's the nice thing is
you can pick up the bounties when you
start the bunker before you go in it to
be like alright how am I going in here
okay cool I can punch stuff sweet
whatever you need to do and go on in and
that's yeah it's a lot of repeatable
bounties I mean Ares said it and I made
a video on it that seems to have some
traction joys of thumbnails that are
clickbait debate but mayhem is honestly
like if you want to like pass some time
watch a Netflix show and destiny at the
same time ma'am just go in there blow
some stuff up every couple matches 26
bits and you get a success yeah it's
like 26 from a match like you can do
three legendary lost sectors you can do
Club public events till you're blue in
the face but just like a quick 5 minute
match probably the fastest thing you can
do now somebody said they got a crap ton
of them from gambit prime I need to go
see how many are dropping you know their
prams lit prompt I can in bandar prime I
can't finish a game why not are you
going are you oh yeah I got the finished
one game all week because I even I got
physically depressed like I kill this
round play two games a game I'm like
guys I'm I'm done for the day
what you getting like oh yeah you get a
beaver be gopher there's my computer
right now and I cannot figure out where
they all are at no camp I know there was
an issue like in the start of the season
like if people leveled up their season
pass while you were in a game you would
kick the other team that was the thing -
you didn't see about that oh yeah hey
it's figured out to that degree
some people had said like if they
leveled up their season pass either
turning in bounties or something during
the match because people would be like
two-thirds through and be like just kick
the other team out or something like
that and then they'd win or lose it was
the weirdest thing I was like this is
bizarre stuff so I haven't touched game
but mostly except just to get the
powerful zazz I was leveling I don't
need to do it anymore but I've been
shelling I've done
- baby gambits and one game at prime
this week that's it baby gambit and is
that's all I could that's all I could
and just like I had a bunch of picked up
a bunch of it drift around like just
delete delete delete I'm done it's fine
Oh next week maybe another time without
right now is it it's sad in here mm-hmm
ya know I was like Iron Man what was the
12th there wasn't much in the dwop it
wasn't much and no I wanted to see your
guys thoughts about the iron banner
quest and banded arms if you played it
last week at all while I clear my throat
I'd always done in four hours with
everything so I had a good run backed it
out
I I understand everyone's frustration
with it mmm
and it's the same thing every season you
have to do this long quest this one we
had we had a weapon attached to it not
just the bounties
I mean if you're really stressed about
knocking it out the first week you're
then you're really stressed about
knocking it out the first week I got
lucky I mean I just I had a nice flow it
was all with the exception of the bow at
the very end which took me I think like
two maybe two and a half games to finish
cuz I finished in the middle of a match
and like get to [ __ ] off of me I can
actually play the game now isn't well
that's that's was where I was going with
all this it's kind of I have a tradition
I always play on iron banner with the
boys when it comes around it's our day
we do it on a Wednesday and what the
quest is is kicking it's just like I'm
not really playing iron banner I'm
playing this quest and it's sometimes
it's stuff I like to do sometimes it's
I'm never gonna use a sidearm
but you know you do you have their fun
they were good they're great I don't
play that way so it took a little bit of
the joy out of you know kickin it with
the guys I'm playing iron banner but
it's over with now it's over with I have
a bowl I'm never going to use I mean fun
of myself it was like me I never used a
bow also me I [ __ ] need a bow I must
check that box all the boxes
I mean Lord Saladin's rewards could do
with some improvement because I I have a
lot of a lot of my high stat armor is
iron banner Armas nope I don't really
want to go and open up 300 iron banner
packages the weapons could use some love
yeah don't we kids so weapon refresh
like I'm like criminals daggers and I
feel you was it a Wolfman I mean I
why don't we can I've never seen iron
banner go for this stretch of time I
might read ah yes I abandoned anew
weapon or you know weapons it would be
maybe a set of two to three it's like
every few months yes
like get a refresh let's be real step
band Whitney Mason yeah take the B team
like I keep telling you oh then we get
remixes of early D tool
I am bana Armour with a slide
I don't know why they weren't ornaments
oh I know yet I don't know why you were
no I agree all should be I don't know
why the faction Armour is back in the
world and it's not just an ornament
because it seems like to me that takes
up space that it shouldn't have to take
up and they don't have this seasonal mod
which I heard they we gonna talk about
it eventually but it's like but I mean
why why go through all of that in the
first place why have every one of my
prime engrams
is a piece of crap old set of armor or
it's one of the faction ones which
doesn't have a mod right now so I got
something with 65 stats I'm like damn
and it doesn't have a mod slot on it I'm
like it's unusable yeah and I can't like
infuse the stats into it I'm just like
cool you're a thousand you're just dead
to me though what the hell like it's oh
that's tough but yeah it's like armor
mmm I have so many issues with armor but
I'm good system's way too busy the
weapons I mean the problem is I've had
the best version of every iron banner
gun forever now me too I see a roar the
bear drop and I'm like I have mine I'm
good woman to raise the frickin that's
disgusting mm-hmm and still don't use it
but it's like I had nine of them in my
inventory I'm like why do I have nine of
these already have the best one yep
so there's no incentive for me to go
open the packages besides to get a
triumph that I really don't care about I
agree I am banning armor and weapons
really have to be addressed like it is
way too long you know we've been crying
about the faction stuff but yeah this is
just there's no incentive and literally
I'm just doing it but pinnacle infusion
so I wanted to this is like this kind of
leads into a topic of what like or ten
my brother and we're talking about last
night had the monitor just talking with
dad what did I miss what did I miss well
it would have been fun last night
because it's something we've talked
about before but you know want to get a
third pair of ears and chat please chime
in on this one because it's the idea so
right now Bungie is in they're in a
tough spot and right now specifically in
the middle of the virus stuff there
tougher spot because they're working
from home you know their their
throughput is not even what it should be
on just bungee being on their own
standards it's even less than it is now
potentially somewhere there's a d3 being
in the works if you we got the b-team on
this if you're saying that one and I
hate saying B team I would say D to D to
live team call them that because they're
better than most of them out there so
that's why I'm say that all right so we
got to say to live alidium that's the
politically correct way we confirm
they're actually working on a d3 we
don't know no one knows where I send me
links [ __ ] they work okay I
believe you
I trust you and another game called math
that's what I was getting towards like
matter is a thing I don't know if that's
Christine Barrett working on Tobias
little colorful logo but somewhere there
was a hundred and fifty million dollars
that came into that company from
Nettie's and then matter got announced
as a thing so and you have next-gen
consoles coming out this fall somebody's
got to be working on a port the UI the
fixes to have that thing run potentially
sixty came higher framerate higher field
of view somebody's got to make sure that
thing runs good on the new consoles if
Sony and Xbox aren't the same either
that's a thing so you have all of those
working against what we're playing right
now right so here's the question and
this is gonna kind of open a can that
we've previously closed so uh would you
Trevor would you rather at this point
this is kind of where I'm Blake we're
sitting here we're like hey we're kind
of like hey the bunkers done when I
login in two weeks
Grand Master nightfall looks like it has
40,000 mean nightfall modifiers on it do
I really want to do that for more tokens
and other stuff are these smaller
seasons that were kind of getting now if
the throughput of Lake you know your
iris and trials is trials weapons should
not have been the limiting factor on the
season because there dude you should
been working on those for two years yet
we know that trials weapons limited
ritual weapons we know that was actually
stated so it's like would you rather
have
either bigger brakes or like say if you
like if you say they are working on d3
is there a point where like do you keep
putting a bad taste in people's mouth
trials coming out broken seasons of
eating small bugs not being QA because
testing is apparently a little shorter
do you continue to do season after
season and then September as forte was
saying is gonna be the bigger idea of
what we're gonna expect for a little
while but do you keep putting that bad
taste in people's mouth so when d3 comes
out they're like I don't want to buy the
third version of this thing you've been
beating me down on for awhile or is
there a point where if Bungie finally is
just candid and is like dude we are
trying to work on d3 even with the virus
especially we late we don't want to keep
putting the seasons out we want to take
a break and work on this new thing so
the whole team is focused is there a
point that you would be either okay with
the break do you lose the playerbase as
we've talked about before do you worry
about the d3 having enough life to come
back where's the break a good or bad
thing so there's like simply question
there may I just say that's like yeah
questions but yeah a little bit I
already got my theory unless he wants me
to go but I read my theory on what's
happening but your theory I've always
been a fan of the expansion part but I
think this this seasons are the break
I think the seasons the way they're
structured is hurry up and wait let's do
this
wait do this thing then the quests gonna
come two weeks do this thing grind that
you know everything is obelisk II you
know what I'm saying and then this whole
serif bunker and putting things in and
charging things up to to time gate and
slow us down for let's be we could do
this thing in about a week if we if you
give us full rein and all these things
are accessible you blaze this so their
whole thing is look we don't got the
resources we don't got the bed hey we've
got matter
we've got d3 David made it it when we
had gcx right they said they couldn't
what was the old name because now it's
called the seasoned pepper won't but I
think was that's called the annual pass
and then wasn't for what's called the
season pass whatever was called before
they said Daniels before these were
season passes right so they said they
couldn't maintain the structure of the a
was too much so they have to make change
and I think that's what we're seeing now
so ultimately they can have enough
bandwidth to do these other things thus
you have the live on it and you know
doing what they do so I mean to me les
I'm not as disgusted because in the back
of my mind I know what's going on and II
you'll be proud of me I've been very
nice you know normally old car I'll be
blasting I'll be like who's working this
big studio this is unacceptable
but I understand what's going on you
know I mean so my thing is we gotta get
d3 hopefully 2020
you know and um not that the thing is
gonna be they've got to knock out cuz
the rock the vibe I'm getting right now
it's one rate here a dungeon a year
I'm warning people now I think they're
already setting this thing up because
they know they're not ready but d3 so I
think the new expansion in September
we'll get the raid will get or what you
call it you know but for now get
funkified get did I believe
this missionary today
I hate to break it to y'all bandits
we're and here's the other thing too
let's be real this is probably the first
time you gonna love my transformation
but this is gonna be the time you have
to dust off that all your backlog
against it you ain't finished
hey if the visioning is but you don't be
eating apples or smiling I see your face
listen I've bent the knee on this I
already see what has happened right so
this is the time go go check out once
you finished your bunker go do do it up
in another game then when they time
untime gate something you come back and
do it's clear stall tactics because the
content is still not there
that's just poppy but manna knows I let
you go you tell me what wrong with me
you're not wrong
mm-hmm wait what you're not wrong
to be in order to bring a new concept
against a point to where stuff's gonna
have to go away they're going to have to
delete stuff I've been joking just
destroy mercury swallow necess I mean
I'm okay with that it would make sense
it's been eating it for three years
I'm like dude somebody like tripped over
the motor and like sorry but I mean
they're releasing content now that's
going away at the end of the season like
we just did the whole sundial thing
which was a nice little you know a
little activity that would have been a
strike I wish that would just stay as
the string like why not well I mean it's
I miss rice remember what we had strikes
so much like I was so excited just to
get that one now almost the one lady
yesterday yeah yeah so good it's the one
that Aerith pops in and I was like oh
how long have you been here you know
said if she's going into a little spiel
my god miss strikes like the little
things man the vendor refresh is is so
and somebody even asked early in a chat
like what would you rather
you know them do this kind of stuff for
you know the Refresh is it it's tough
it's tough but it could take you oh I
was just saying I mean d3 is eventually
going to happen we're all going to buy
it we're all addicted we're not going to
abandon our community our friends so I
mean listen let's be very real d2
vanilla was not ready it was a hot mess
we all still bought it we all still
played it and I mean you're gonna run
into content droughts where I mean I did
it myself
I jumped off and I started playing
Rainbow six and see a thieves for like
20 minutes I did that that was fine I
was I was awesome 20 minutes I mean to
be fair to rare I mean they they were
Microsoft beat the [ __ ] out of them to
get that game out they were very
transparent about what was going on
behind the scenes if you go play see
he's not that's a fantastic game but
they they got in front of all the bad
press that listen we know it's not
perfect but this is what we did today
like they'd have weekly live up on yes
yep and I'm like that's amazing and so
down all respect to them so yeah but I
am gonna make [ __ ] funny [ __ ] but
yeah you're gonna get to those points
where you gonna have to go find
something else to do and it's ok it's ok
you don't have to make a public
announcement
I'm quitting destiny well crack and quit
for the eighth time you [ __ ]
you'll see I'll see you when the next
DLC drops it's fine mags but uh an order
of likes to get another Forsaken
something's probably gonna have to go
away at this point I mean there's going
to be a large piece of content going
Nexus look well like you know he was
making a joke but the Leviathan eating
Nessus and then Leviathan going away
that would free up all kind of space
yeah I mean
I mean it's sad because we always had
the raids all the way through to age of
triumph you know but the day is not
yesterday so if you need to clear space
I mean there's not a whole lot of people
running LaVon I did it this week got
some people nice enough to help me get
through it because I'm still trying to
finish my a crius yeah three or four
years later the final catalyst version
or whatever I think I'd stab wound or
Mille I'm have to do the prestige
that'll be a nightmare because I'm a
horrible I'm collaborating Lazarus to
drop the bomb and a chat and I've been
thinking about this I got it I got there
I asked was the separation of Bungie
from Activision a good thing now that
we've had a year to digest it that is a
very good question very good good I got
a big do you eat what do you think this
before you know we had we had these
sauces we had bad with we had pigs what
do you think
go back under the evil umbrella these
are what I would call growing pains and
they are brutal right now because bungee
either had capacity salary whatever was
there before multiple studios helping I
don't know how big they were but
obviously they're bigger than we think
they were
I still think hopefully if I think I
would that I can only answer that
question when I see what d3 turns into
because right now the seasons are as
you're saying their way to get to their
next vision mm-hmm so and I don't know
for that version we've been able to be
them without activision but it's like I
think I'll have to see d3 before I can
finally answer that question but let's
enter the question right now as of what
we've seen right now we're full year
right how long's it been
I mean shadow keep was pretty sweet
shadow keep yeah shadow keep was dead
right so we haven't without a full year
yet right represents the first DLC -
yeah so September will be a full year
this will be a full year separation okay
so up until this point how are you
feeling about Bungie solo let's get it
man of arms
might answer your question with a
question mm-hmm have you been paying
attention to what the distributors are
doing to other games right
any ever been good no
the question because they are literally
well I mean what they're literally doing
isn't so the whole loop box thing still
exists but it's not as prolific as it
was it's not as predatory I got I got a
counter I've got to get uh you can make
the argument that ever verse is worse
than it ever was under Activision with
Bungie I don't buy [ __ ] it's fine you
can fade it but they still do it the
practice they're sitting there and
they're just the same if you want a big
apology for stuff that costs more and
just as much as the expense it is stuff
it's the the pricing the pricing can be
tweaked yeah I'm not gonna argue that
I'm not gonna argue that I don't buy a
lot of stuff at the universe but I see
something I like I'm like this is
expensive I still buy it why cuz I'm a
grown-ass man with money it's fine I can
do okay all right Exhibit B bugs we have
seen the most unstable broken version of
the game since they have left there's
every week there's something wrong there
desert is a beaver there's a exotic
that's broken there's oh we get a chance
to pick the I got I got I got evidence
man we could go through these date of
like dusty to where we had our sugar
daddy these problems we're not exist
activision that's what do you censor me
okay we didn't have these issues right
it's a bunch of guy with a baby not
about better this I'm talking about they
like shut him down he is not invited to
the studio no more I get it Bungie but I
gotta talk to the people when Activision
around we didn't have these issue every
week we've got a problem
Bell winters disabled that's the come on
man at all to come on real games the
billikin look at how much new stuff is
being released ever
all the time more than new items new
gear new exotics
all the stuff new activities hmm I am
NOT a programmer once you introduce one
thing into the ecosystem that is a game
world with the potent quotes spaghetti
code that [ __ ] just goes wrong it's
gonna happen something now that I'm I'm
not defending Bungie as far as there
have been things in the past they should
have tested more and should have caught
and I've screamed from the rafters like
how how how did you do this but when you
introduce a handful exotics for each
class and you throw that into a new
activity things are going to happen the
connect with the connectivity you can
absolutely blame what's going on in the
real world right now okay because the
bandwidth that is being absorbed by the
Internet service providers right is well
yeah absolutely that be insurmountable
in little Janene like listen you can
watch Netflix and next ship flick so go
hold on I got to take a break all right
and it'll just be like there's no signal
and you just you have to wait it out all
of a sudden your movie starts back up
because there's more people at home
there's probably more people at
different times a day playing on the
bungee server that
they'd I mean how many people really
play at nine o'clock in the morning on a
weekday let's be real what I mean but
it's written most most people will be
playing after five six o'clock in the
evening and vice versa as the time zones
ago and when you go around the world you
know you have more people on the servers
right now that's out sanity say what
don't forget to tell y'all about the
missing currency twice that's just [ __ ]
gonna happen excuse me
it's gonna break [ __ ] you put new [ __ ]
in the game [ __ ] is gonna break well and
that's gonna think we're on season 10 we
had three years as you're saying either
with with more spacing by the way for
testing so we had d1 we had rota we had
Wolves with T and we had House of wolves
and we had take it
picking King that was literally over the
course of two years there were and then
like d1 obviously had those things
obviously pre-loaded kind of planned out
before but you had taken King you had a
year you had an entire year with nothing
you had no exotic energies an 18-month
shotgun meta when that happened - yeah
but daddy had to get the whip get bungee
in the shape not as no one to ever know
but that's not that's not the whole
point is not you are on season 10 of
exotics going in you have 80 I think
there's a little a hundred and fifty
exotics in the game between weapons and
armor at some point and they could bring
three newest season and they try them
some don't work and look okay so testing
and it's just like this the speed at
which stuff is coming at this point is
continuous and ongoing so on top of like
the Internet issues with steam they're
trying the new like steam ID instead of
IP so people don't get DDoS other
cheating is an issue but that's the
thing so they have that the launches at
the same time with error codes and then
on top of trying to continually feed you
stuff it's the idea of like do you want
the break or do you want the you know do
you want this stuff to keep going well
also in in the real world how many you
don't actually have a ton of people
physically at the studio right so that's
but let's know more now now I gotta stop
you listen dad this device to just
happen we had all these problem before
like the virus all from always directly
reset for example this is an excuse for
everything but like totally reset so the
weekly recess generally like five
minutes the weekly reset was thirty five
minutes right the reason there's a
weekly reset is they literally go into
the bungee circuit and physically
physically this and reset the server and
refresh the server these you have to
have people go into a workplace that is
a quarantine workplace maybe you're
using two guys instead of 10 and then
when [ __ ] reboots and shits not right
well you got two guys there to try and
fix it and get it back on so I mean
things like this are gonna happen the
fixes are going to slow down but
bunch is very transparent when you buy
[ __ ] on ever verse for money it goes to
Bungie mmm is it overpriced a lot of it
is overpriced a lot of it is overpriced
but the question is no we listen like
you said if you want to buy it buy right
it's up to you that no one's putting a
gonna nobody's headed by sticking nobody
up to go by you know these ornaments
right but we have to admit based on a
lot of this because I see people at the
top table with all this stuff off so
people are buying it right so my thing
is remember when Luke came out with the
whole um what's he did what he would
transparent blog that he does listeners
director's cut alright he had made a
point that said hey cuz of this blah
blah blah and got spent on this whatever
verse we was able to do that paid for a
zero our that paid for this I want to
know what's paying for lista whatwhat
are we getting now man I'm sure I'm just
saying man cuz I'm not I'm not seeing
that yet your does the house like that
money into the d3 bank
so that's d3 I'm guessing we just talked
about like matter d3 next-gen and the
live service seasons income place you
want to put that money that you're
putting in there all of them could go to
mukha much less time to do an exotic
beverly's like are we gonna get an
exotic cuesta season I'm not even
holding my breath and I want one
Langham cuz we have the final month of
the season that's kind of open they say
there's more to go after Guardian games
that's literally a month left of the
season once it's out there
it says and more doctors there's a lot
of stuff that's been date of mind I'm
not gonna yeah I talked about it here
yeah so there's stuff out there
and all I wish I wish I would not know
about it yeah you know you should just
put all the spoilers in your YouTube
thumbnail and post that on social that's
fine it's my fault I subscribed to you
subscribe I can't even get trials Awards
on time I have to wait for a separate
reset day so I could get the brand-new
Act that's a fact
he said they definitely to pay for a
better server better it's a cheat he
said this boy I better get your forte
going it that is true about that trials
separate recent day was sad of it I
don't understand I mean wow yo-yo okay
why would you even play before 5:00 p.m.
on Saturday dough that's it
I get that it sucks and you know they're
they're fixing it Tuesday
supposedly according to the twelve why
would you plan on Friday though after
they told you that you wasn't gonna get
they told you this is not good and you
figure at 5:01 p.m. on Saturdays when
you'd have the most people in there
playing like that'd be the best time to
go in know it like straight 101 p.m. est
people in trials people thirst they
don't have I don't have any rewards I
had to bring it up he's just gonna stick
just for argument's sake now obviously
it's the year they're not been a full
year yet with them men on it all but I
do want to always you know I'm saying be
transparent with what's going on now if
it continues post virus I'm gonna bring
this back up remember that time we had
matter I was on and we was trouble I'm
gonna bring this there so I just want
y'all to be cognizant that's on their
own there has been and you guys have
made legitimate reasons
and I get it none of the stuff you're
saying is incorrect I'm just I just got
my eye open because it's concerning if
it continues all the way up into
September and hopefully once the world
gets back together and you know they can
start getting back into the office stuff
like that you know I definitely hope you
don't things sell in but I'm just
watching them I'm away you know me I'll
be yelling I'll be the first one yelling
it's like I don't even know why they
listen to me at this point because I
talk out of both sides of my face
constantly so I get it but let me ask
you this now
we had a lot of complaints several
months back mm-hmm about they were
laying out the road maps yes and telling
us way too much right right now I'm
starting to read some backlash but we
really don't know what we got this
season or that's kind of what we asked
what I kinda asked to not know what was
good I'll be ok they said listen this
this season it's all about Rasputin did
it and that's it I don't need to know
that well I got what was the one that
got ruined
it was horrible uh season was completely
ruined ya know the force she was
completely ruined because we were given
way too much information but because
Niobe Labs would have played out
completely differently if you didn't
know there was yet another force to
unlock after I know B last if we'd have
been kept in the dark about that that
would have been a great season it had
been like this past thing with it was
the the the holes of time or whatever we
didn't know what was really gonna happen
we had an ad a good idea it was like
okay so this is gone locked yet another
another stage of this but we had already
kind of been prepared my note but no but
I was like everybody's posted hexagons
were like what
so there's gonna be it's like how how
much do we want to know how much do we
want to be kept in the dark to where
it's a surprise and its pleasant it's a
it's it it's an immersive journey right
and then who do they listen to because
you know none of us can agree on
anything right as far when it comes to
this that we all have our our difference
we all have our safe word kicks in a
different time no but like Prescott said
and you said it was like the community
is basically sits a schizophrenic when
it comes to what they ask for it's like
we want this but we don't want this but
a little more but not too much info it's
like what do you want it's like Bungie
tries to walk this is the delicate line
of how do you play
there's no way to appease everybody and
anymore it seems like there's no way to
appease anybody you're gonna beat too
much too little too fast too slow not
enough content content all the time this
is too small but it's too big but I got
bounties oh you want bounties we're
gonna give you a thousand bounties okay
now I'm doing two bounties all the time
I don't like bounty it's like it's this
ongoing cycle and that's why this game
continues to live and evolve and we just
were here for the journey and I think
that's just part of it I'm gonna be very
imma probably piss a few people off okay
that's gonna have it comments are fun
and like this point in in terms of PvP
like when we're sitting we're having a
constructive conversation about the
reward system and we're trying to find a
way to get more people to play yes
that's the kind of feedback they should
listen to mm-hmm as far as weapon tuning
and all this they just need to close
their ears now and when they do a meta
shift if they do want to do a metal
shift every season every two seasons
okay so we did a medic that's a sidearm
meta that's what it is and that's what
you're going to play and that's it and
in next season we're gonna change it to
something else
and then that's what you'll play and
that's gonna be the medic cuz it's a
meta shift and we don't want to hit you
can you scream all you want we're not
listening just say point like we're not
listening this is a meta shift this is
it's an auto rifle meta that's what it
is this season if you don't like playing
with auto rifles that's fine
don't play with auto rifles and go get
smoked you don't have to community to
man in our view to be like and you just
do that spiel okay why doesn't it but
the exception I mean not forgotten hand
cannon again switched from a 180 to a
150 why does nobody ever complain about
hand cannons mm-hmm well it's a high
skill weapon great you want to play a
high-risk high-reward weapon that's on
you don't miss I'm sorry it's okay if
you want to show off for your viewers I
love hand cannons I love hand cannons I
am
competitive with them because I'm gonna
miss okay so I gotta use a pulse rifle I
gotta use something else or I have to
have a good backup plan mmm is it if you
don't want to play with hard light fine
play with play with suros regime sir
regime is great there's a 60% of great
there's some 720s that will shred a 600
that nobody's talking about because you
the range is severe you got to be close
but you will destroy somebody using a
600 a 720 but this is our Mehta play it
or don't it's fine raids exist go raid
I'll see you go red example you don't
like it go raid the game because guess
what this is where it is if it's not
constructive in a way that is trying to
get more people engaged in the game to
make the game better I really don't care
anymore I don't care I don't care that
you tapped me with a thorn get out of
the face the hard life which I already
agreed on it on the double damage we
agree with the end no range fall-off is
the issue so it's always been that way
it's been that way since d1
no not with this level of accuracy
stability now if you bailed on me if you
use it we will make fun of you
there's no five times the about of usage
first reputable but I'm gonna make fun
of you
it's I made a video the first video ever
made was on that weapon it's a it was a
trash gun I'm going to make fun I'm
gonna make fun of you when you if you
were a bottom tree striker running
juggernut I made fun of you I'm a
striker why because it's it's its weak
play how you want it's okay we might
make fun of you though that's fine but
do is dominating the better
you mentioned the range fall-off though
it's like an area set of two you try and
actually out shoot me with a go figure
with that thing at range I'm gonna win
it still compete it's right me will go
one-on-one here in a minute go
everywhere you're like hey ray I can hit
you across the map I'm like I'm gonna
hit you nine
at attending your time range I'm just
talking about what I consider rage to
and reigns what is a good attitude and
I'll preload a your that yeah but you're
using a one of the dominant weapons I'm
trying to say is I just feel autos right
off fine overall but that gun is
competing in other places where it
technically shouldn't be out dueling
these other weapons that's the first
time six years that gun gets to see a
little bit of the mount useful from the
next gun are you kidding me
that is like the ultimate crutch because
it's the first time that it's being used
it's no this is not right like this how
good is broken how much how much and
you're rewarding missing you I could
shoot down the hallway miss Abby I got
you know this is not the way a as
man-at-arms said it is the meta swallow
it move on how much usage did my ticket
on that's not if the numbers I've never
seen this much a disparity I'm a little
boy whose gun to the number two she's
good
this is like night day is that way
people were using spare rations
beforehand oh come on Ares 5 times
Ares comment you know yes unset it son
said weapon retiring like weapon
retirement Webber retired at it's not
let me okay let me ask it now that
objectively is the is it as broken as
Lord of wolves has been
I think so because it's the most
versatile gun in any situation you could
use it in any situation lot of wolves
was strictly at close range
I can shoot somebody down close define
close give me meters go meters meters
tons of meters if I'm thinking in his
face is where it should win it should
have that level of accuracy that's all
I'm saying
it's the Stax prove what I'm saying
until y'all could show me another manner
where the number one gun was used five
times the amount of the number to land
lab trials and who's getting kills in
trials the sweaty people the sweaty
people are aware of the meta so then if
you go into a casual playlist where not
everybody watches YouTube videos there
they up they listen to podcast they're
like hey what's the top thing going on
right now then yeah the average person
is gonna be like okay so they're gonna
probably use some more average too late
you go in crucible I don't see it that
much in crucible I see in trials because
the sweat is who are very in tune with
the meta what are strong guns and things
of that nature and guess what it's one
of the most obvious tells hey that guy
killed me with the laser lightshow what
weapon did he use it's not like a bullet
you guys are fine would you despair we
already talked about the whole you
remove the lifting right anything else
you do you are gutting an exotic that
has been around forever they'll take
away the change take away the Ricochet
damage are good I said in what else you
can't do anything else absolutely do
some more stuff and you'll get it and
then you won't use it anymore
listen 600 is still in a good place my
only issue with the gun is besides that
the thing is at range at range I still
feel it's it's not it's no drop off it's
actually probably one of the only few
guns that because it's a laser beam
right there's Leonard hop off yeah I was
like it okay yeah it probably should
been hard late you're firing light
mmm that shouldn't have much of a
drop-off it travels pretty quick pretty
sure I like all rifles competing down
the block y'all cool with that
now cool with that and then you know how
I feel about auto rifles in general oh I
know you hate our service place so you
don't hate them I'm just saying that you
just shaking there he easy but yo of
course but hey shouldn't they shouldn't
be competing with people with a skill
weapon at distance that that's just my
from hand cannon should we head to range
they hit at ever they got completely UNC
a range means not lethal hand cannon
right now they got brought in from the
ranges it didn't work
it got to last note um stills like a
rush this is still good I'm still
smoking like spare rations is still on
that list spec Corrections is still good
look at the disparity between the
rations and the other weapons it's all
close all the other stuff is very close
except in my opinion with the exception
of I'm gonna hold the trigger down and
bounce it down the hallway Soros's
better yeah freakin amazing
once Soros gets cranked up you destroy
families like you destroy people's
accounts it's horrible okay so the hard
light gets nervous arose comes up you're
gonna knock that down next every
everyone be complaining about five times
Bartlet's neurosis is gonna leap I'm not
is Leon but I'm just talking about the
disparity they do everything gun the mr.
Fixit that's what it is
throws can fail you and still compete
with hardlight it does not heal you all
the time is a percentage versus it
literally said it can okay that's the
word choice there right can and it still
competes with the gun you're complaining
about so we can what is the difference
here's a difference
suros has to spin up you have to have
that level before they get there whereas
Harley is there from from the RIP
that's everything i'll pre-fire hand
cannons coming around the corner just in
case just in case somebody walks in
front of it I will have no problem
shooting down an empty hallway somebody
will walk in front of it eventually
fiction here's the thing you're
confusing something leading the UM the
weapons usage rate as the issue that's
that's not this is always gonna be
something that's gonna bleed but when
you have disparity as this which is
rarely seen that is the problem that it
be there's one clear solution to life's
problems in PvP that's what I'm saying
this big is the solution bro - yo guys
show me a meta where y'all at the one
gun was used five to seven times more
than everything else then I say you know
what you got me that meta was evil
they're places you can look that up by
the way
I'm like how what like I want to know
what the usage rate for Lord of wolves
was in comp when it was popular how
often was one-eyed mask used in common
when it was popular like oh that was so
I'm like go through the reigns that some
of these things have had recluse recluse
holy [ __ ] that was bigger than anything
for the longest time but I mean
you can you can go through it's just
like again yeah it's a yeah sure we did
numbers I've not seen I've moved there
bro there's no other site tracks at like
trials this launched with trials but
those previously that crucible stats
we've got comps nobody has the like the
specific trials weapon report that I
posted on Twitter and you're like no
here it is there's not other but we have
got Charlamagne all stuff they still
have usage rates their 808 able animals
what subclasses killed we still we've
always had that okay one we've had that
so what you couldn't tell me what it was
then
because it wasn't that ridiculous to be
like they don't know what the disparity
will I guarantee you it had to be pretty
damn ridiculous for a couples moment
vision to be a long time I have never
seen this much disparity I'm just
telling I look at those type of okay so
if you take away the Ricochet how do you
not gut it so it just goes one two
literally [ __ ] how do you not take it
into a dumpster
it's an order rife all you wanted isn't
you just hate he just want it gone
Hey Tovah rule over has passed it
officially revoke her is the most shoes
weapon in trials
100,000 kills but the new boy that's a
new number why we've been talking about
hardlight revoke her is now the problem
obviously so do you have any issues with
revoke er
with the whole park just going in and
yeah that's how the gun works have any
issues with that guttin its how the gun
works
I mean it's a sniper so I'm a little
partial more partial back that uh it
still requires some skill to stanked I
just struggled with auto rifle I do I
just rose I'm cool with you but uh old
art I like me
Prescott's week Colombo off the Ricochet
don't get rid of it your friction urals
not your one was this bad
Reles pretty bad dead there shouldn't be
no ricochet bonus damage yeah it never
should have been on the gun
it's to see what they would do Uriel's
year one actually was really really bad
yours real what was strong is a hundred
percent correct what it was the counter
cuz we had like a neo yet like two or
three guns
like that's how always remember the Olli
was always like two or three no Uriel's
was my scout rifle I'm not even joking
oh yeah no that thing's range is nuts
it's still pretty damn good now when you
[ __ ] this range was all in your one get
strange that all of it all of it all the
range what's the idea here they take
away the room I'd want to know where
with Lane because then people wouldn't
be blind firing all the time no and then
you know it's probably gonna feel a
little different but yeah there's your
solution to that don't go out there they
will they will listen I ran out of
bullets but hardlight I didn't think
that was possible Ike I'm legit out of
bullets I have two shotgun shells Oh
like a 10 kill streak and ran out of
bullets and the Lions in sixes and I was
just I was it's on this video log
somewhere I'm like dude I'm out of
bullets
you killed families and that's what
happened oh that was ran over seven a
day yeah yeah no I that's see whatever
well well we're brokers gonna muddy the
waters because that's that's oh well
that's what everybody's complaining
about now then Ghana's broken okay well
then next week we'll be playing on
anomaly again or something and everybody
we're using something else I was like
maps are gonna determine you what do you
guys think the messing up these are very
strong no idea cold I wanted to do that
I wanted to be exited yeah actually this
is the word for blue home yep that's the
anyone yeah I want that I love them it's
got some quarters and stuff called her
it'll be interesting as well it'll be
able to be one of those two after that
don't know go whole school Twilight
let's go while they go with no sniper
lanes anymore good luck with that
it's like wings all over the place up
top don't go to the right and jump
outside oh yeah but you can't stand on
the end of the railroad tracks anymore
and see the other side of the map that
doesn't boxes bags in the way no what
does you got you I'm trying to think it
was like I feel like the basically they
in the tois they mentioned cheating and
they mentioned the fact that all the
little displays on your emblems they
have a lot of those that they will be
bringing back but it was an ultra-light
[ __ ] bob outside of cheating calendar
that we've seen and and patches and
stuff that are in the works and that's
about it but the biggest thing is like
the end of the table and I'll just read
it cuz the Dylan said it and said it
pretty damn well the days and weeks are
beginning and meld together our local
weather station put it we've entered the
month of map roll airy basically cuz
yeah every day does run together the Sun
continues to rise and fall but it's
becoming a little difficult to keep
track of what data's thankfully we have
destiny to to bring us together during
these times of isolation sometimes the
only thing I have to remind me of is
what day of the week we are living is
every Thursday main status blog article
I'd like to take a moment to highlight
the essential workers of the world and I
wanted to do that as well thank you to
everybody out there in the world be it
like teachers if you guys are trying to
do live classrooms from home parents who
now have a rude awakening of what the
teacher
are going through on a day-to-day basis
then the health care workers in the
front lines doing all the stuff they're
doing risking themselves with not enough
equipment to do what they're supposed to
be doing so stay home stay safe and try
and stay healthy so we can try and get
through this thing I just wanted to
throw that out there Lou actually I got
something to chime in on this yes and
this is it this is gonna be the complete
opposite of everything else we talked
about this is very serious a lot of
places so when they do a lockdown you
have the essential businesses which are
black and white but a lot of other
businesses stay open because they're
given the provision you can stay open as
long as you follow the CDC safety
guidelines listen we all need a paycheck
I get it if your workplaces legitimately
putting you in situations where you are
at risk to infect yourself or someone
else or your family members when you get
home pick up a phone and report them I
mean listen some people gotta pay bills
I get it
I have friends right now at work they
have to pay their bills so they're going
to work their workplace is not nearly
ideal so I mean at the end of the day
it's your life so do what you gotta do
but don't be afraid to call [ __ ] on
an employer who's not doing things
correctly when they are fully capable
doing it correctly
I mean it's a shitty situation either
way you cut it because you gotta get
paid yeah but it's not it's not worth
your life
absolutely yeah you got to put your life
first you got to put your health first
you got to protect yourself protect your
fab because again he'd been you know
younger or whatever who may feel the hey
something happens to me I could survive
it you know you being someone as a
carrier could really do damage you know
just someone so long yeah you gotta be
careful you gotta be coming if it feel
wrong don't do it don't do it man oh my
shop closed down on purpose because it's
like we cannot do business safely and it
sucks I mean a lot of guys are you know
the low-level guys they live paycheck to
paycheck and unfortunately we had to
make a decision it was just like
we gotta go home yeah you gotta leave
yeah most of the guys who were upset
about us like do you have little kids
yeah I got a two-year-old bro
this is for you two year old yeah and
there's perfect there's provisions for
income I mean that that's what this
whole stimulus package they just passed
for is and it does really favor people
with lower incomes right you're in the
upper bracket of income you pass seventy
five thousand is it does nothing for you
but though you know you should have
saved your money I'm in that group I
save some money I'm okay but
so there's provisions to make sure you
stay afloat there's moratoriums on rent
moratoriums on mortgage but you don't
have to pay those bills electric will
not turn off in a lot of places stuff in
place at the end of day you still have
to feed your family too so I completely
get that not everybody's situation is
the same so if the question is taking on
risk and feeding my child
roll on broken glass and through fire so
I get that to the all I'm saying is do
what you gotta do and last thing I was
just add to it Islam look we're all
gamers here you know everyone here loves
gaming play that's being do all this
stuff now is the time man it's a
beautiful toss the first game is this is
what we do we stay inside blaze so that
but you just telling us to do what comes
natural but there's a lot of my friends
a lot of people who are not gamers are
really struggling with the whole
isolation thing not tell him pick up a
console and I'm saying do some things to
get your mind off in a lot of the
negativity while we go through it and we
will get through it
apparently they bring to plays Animal
Crossing yes and Wow far great I'm
afraid to turn it on I'm late again am I
gonna be like you know loan-sharking
with Tom Nook and worrying about turn up
stock markets and I'm like I don't know
if I can get into that yo have you got
Tom crossing is the coronavirus of games
it's like the cartoon cutest real life
simulator where you have a loan you
don't there's no payback date but you
still got a loan and Tom Knox got you
well I got these turnips oh my they all
my farm crop got ruined so my harvest
can't go turn in so I can pay the stock
market I'm like what game did you guys
make that is like that's the stuff I
keep seeing how somebody's like I made a
million bells on turnips right now and
I'm [ __ ] humping this tree to get wood
to get it and I'm digging the holes
behind me so I can knock rocks like 20
times I'm like if I get into that I'm so
worried I saw somebody made a picture of
Shaq's in-game on Animal Crossing I was
like I could never I can never mess with
this whole thing's just just fire in
rivers of beer if you can change the
river to another color you're not gonna
be doing like the bamboo stick to hop
over it you're just gonna be swimming
through it and drunk on the other side
that'd be amazing
I hate look my friends all play edible
Crossley like it's the big stalks mark
it salute salute well we got a respect
today it is kind of right at our usual
stopping time so man-at-arms if you want
to let them know where they can find all
the things that you do between podcast
stream twitch twitch and love your way
if you go to destiny unfiltered com
that'll get you to everything so they'll
guess you're my Twitter my sleeping
YouTube my twitch channel all these
things if you follow me on Twitter
I'm warn you up front you're gonna get a
shitload of alerts over the course of a
day I have no respect for your news feed
but it's entertaining most of the time
so that's fine it is stuff I highly
recommend the follows that is good times
just just turn your alerts off you'll be
fine good we've been talking for know
thank you guys so much
this is though though we had to do it
babe in arms and here a lot of fun you
know I forget if you can tell that's
like one more time
no it could be disturbed destiny
unfiltered calm we do our own thing we
don't know what that thing is but we do
it every week no doubt that's okay let
them know when unfilter goes down what
would we do it live on Twitch Tuesdays
9:00 p.m. Eastern and then audio
trickles out depending on how bad we
screwed up the audio I feel you I feel
you is like what's the other go well
it's when I'm gonna match everything
yeah if it's kids gonna get there
audio is one day one day you will be out
usually within a week or so less than a
week I love it so much
well knows that absolutely man great to
have you on no definitely got me uh got
my cheeks hurt in this morning that's
good we got some laughs laughs what we
need right now actually I was really
looking forward to having a nice
conversation with a lot of levity in it
at this point in time in the world it's
a good thing yeah Cognito sir you
already don't man little kognito act
Lorca they don't want water every Sunday
is the Lord's Day we shall return who we
got we got oh we got show on Capri
that's a more Canadian influence coming
through it should be fun man we're gonna
talk about what's going on with Xbox
what's going on with last of us to delay
we're gonna talk about a little switch
action and maybe what's going on with
cloud infrastructure so stay tuned
Sunday 1:00 p.m. Eastern
I love podcast your YouTube and you
already know cuz he hates what I said
the best destiny podcast you've never
heard on Fridays at 9:00 a.m. Eastern
Market is hot my issue we you need to
say that like other you need to say that
during iron Lords podcast as they just
listen to this and you like the thing
you haven't heard I'm like oh no they
just listen to it that's that's my own
nation
just not in the end of what they just
listened to and I'm you should record it
and post that just that spiel I'm gonna
give you that cliff and you can drop
baby like hey lastwords gonna be at the
best podcast you've never heard of right
anything that gets him upset because he
doesn't get upset so when you get a bit
I see the face of Mike yes now if you
actually had a good enough break in
there I just edit it out but I haven't
find a good break yet just be like [ __ ]
gone it's Eve on ttis everywhere I'm
working from home the way most you guys
are so I'm streaming a lot but if you
find ebon tiss eb o and t is twitter
youtube which if you find a cheetah you
found me
well I'm usually pretty easy to spot
that way but now man this was amazing
hopefully you guys enjoyed it this
morning and all of you guys in chat
don't run away I gotta go raid somebody
on Twitch so don't leave me yet we're
gonna make sure somebody gets a little
love this morning but to end this thing
and editing always makes the sexually
impossible I always kind of good a
little wrap-up let him know the episode
number and then I say it has been and
then the end of this we say the last
word hence the title of the podcast but
we try and say it all together so I'll
edit it later so it actually matches cuz
discord is impossible but we'll do this
together it's not bad with editing I've
learned that it's not too bad so episode
97
we've only got three more until we get a
hundred we are working on a guest for a
hundred so you do not want to miss out
working on that one but it is April 3rd
hopefully you guys stay safe protect
yourself as much as you can
our guest man-at-arms destiny unfiltered
calm go find this man may good times
good laughs and definitely muffs cover
the earmuffs earmuffs on the kids there
keep them safe April 3rd thank you guys
very much
all of you
in chat you guys are awesome and it has
been the last word